Jim Jeffries is coming in hello Jim
welcome in yeah yeah come on in
yeah you just you just flew here just
got off the point about I tell you
Wow well thanks for coming in yeah
welcome thank you so having me hey you
who do talked about Jim when he was in
was um oh my god Rob O'Neill and he
mentioned you he said you guys hang out
how do you know him well I I met him a
friend of a friend said that he wanted
to meet me and I was like yeah I'm a the
guy who shot bin like he's a good guy
too going drink with because if you get
into a fight in a bar you like her I
[ __ ] him and I got I got the guy shot
bin Laden I'll be right in this fight do
they all know who he is or no he's the
word he's the worst at keeping the
secret like he came the first time I met
him II actually he came over to my house
for a barbecue and I was like I had all
my friends before sitting around like a
few comics you probably know it and I
was like okay I'm not meant to tell you
all right
I meant to keep this secret but the guy
who shot bin Laden is coming over right
now don't say anything but you know
you'll know who he is like that right
and he comes over and there's like three
other sort of Navy SEALs with him who
don't have as it an attractive a
girlfriend and then these [ __ ] ginger
[ __ ] comes over with his smoke and
like that's the guy shot ya within like
a few minutes I walked up to him and
said hey look I didn't tell anyone but I
know I know who you are and I thanks for
what you did and then he went what that
I shot do you think they knew like after
the mission was completely like okay
which one shot bin Laden Rob got him
yeah he's one guy that's pressing the
t-shirt up the stairs to do it there was
a guy in front of him and then he opened
the door and then he dragged because bin
Laden had two of his wives standing in
front of him drag the wives off and then
Rob shot him and it's like man that's
the [ __ ] difference between winning
the lottery and not like with yeah you
know I dragged a girl
wives off of him yeah nice story but
who's the guy that shot ya
I open the door he's a [ __ ] buzz
aldrin of ya first man you said to walk
it no no but I was on the same trip yeah
I don't know yeah he's just an
interesting guy is that what we did on
the TV sure we do feel peace with me and
Rob went out and shot some guns and he
taught me about differently we shot a
sniper rifle a watermelon each and at
the end of the piece we thought that'd
be a nice little ending we both shoot Oh
[ __ ] watermelon or whatever he missed
he missed and I think that he plays it
off like I you know I was a bit for
comedy Sandra know he [ __ ] missed man
and then like we show that one that he
missed and then he walks over and he
goes because yeah and he starts looking
at it like oh maybe the alignment on
this one cuz he had another go missed
again and I was like why do you have a
[ __ ] go my god my god works missed
again
wow it was maybe I don't know he never
got it he was like four or five guys in
the end all these artists went out was a
[ __ ] not far these guns can shoot like a
couple of miles this is this thing like
like I ran over and place the watermelon
and ran back like it I don't know 200
meters is it possible that he just got
lucky with the bin Laden thing I think I
maybe he's not a sniper he shot bin
Laden pretty close it was a silty that's
right
the guy's the real [ __ ] did yeah I
always think that's because I met one
time I went and went out drinking with
him and there was like a few other
members of SEAL Team six what did the
other SEAL Teams do what were the first
five yeah I'm a Navy SEAL SEAL Team six
no team four but full still forward
craft services so with you at the team
six that was with him or other mom when
I say just some B's it was like three or
four guys it wasn't you know the whole
remember the whole team but I've hung
out with him I also once went over to he
rang up he said I'm drinking with a
friend called Charlie on it was [ __ ]
charleshayne that was a surreal like you
hang with Charlie Sheen Charlie Sheen
and Rob O'Neil and me all got got
hammered over at Charlie Sheen's house
once yeah Wow how was that it was I was
the most sober person
I remember thinking yeah that's like the
jolly Eddie's girlfriend there and stuff
it was just them old telling story
there's not much more to the story than
that than the fact I probably I'll just
name dropped with no story Charlie Sheen
and Rob O'Neil definitely have better
stories in comic I mean I think Charlie
Sheen probably has the best stories as
well as ones where you sit down you shut
up and you just go okay you tell me Toyo
because you realize as you're sitting
there with Charlie Sheen and Rob O'Neil
my best story is sitting here with Rob
O'Neil and Charley yeah yeah this is
happening right now so I'm gonna let you
guys carry the weight on this one yeah
he's got he's got a lot of baseball
memorabilia that's like loves baseball
league loads of [ __ ] like some
contract that [ __ ] Babe Ruth's signed
or some [ __ ] hanging up on his balls and
you just had one girlfriend with him he
did yeah Charlie and he had the the one
girlfriend that was after bree olson and
whoever that other one was was they were
long gone by that stage yeah yeah that
the two point brie and the other girl
were like his his two side he was the
goddess is that what he called them yes
that whole era with what happened when
he was just doing that winning and what
type of stuff we have to test deposit
I'm guessing this from not long positive
why afterwards because those girls over
sorry
they got tested on TV see bree olson
claims she doesn't like they all got
tested afterwards I thought tiger blood
and all that she knows was power no no
it's alright I got blood something to do
with a Apocalypse Now and yeah yeah I
didn't realize he started doing all the
winning stuff and completely changed he
did the winning stuff as he was leaving
whatever the teenage man yeah I've
spoken to a few people that worked on
that show and they reckon he always
showed up right
anyway I reckon that's the one they
couldn't really pin him because they
were like ah he's cars being pushed off
an edge of a cliff in Malibu and he's
taking cocaine it
they reckon he showed up everyday and
knew his lines and [ __ ] that was why
they couldn't really far
they went you're a bad person but he was
the one on set that was [ __ ]
delivering everything right I'm doing
the job asked I can do and when I'm not
doing the job don't worry carrot the
character was playing a dead base right
yeah I thought the show was better
without him just like Roseanne the
Connors was much better you like it
still going is that still I haven't
heard of real buzz about season I think
it's still on but the only reason I
think it's still on is because I haven't
heard that it's off I like now that
Roseanne is just cuttin loose she's just
going to airports going ah there's no me
to like she's gone like oh yeah now
there's nothing to lose there's nothing
to lose you put her in a position where
there's nothing to lose so she is she's
gonna just sit there and say like me to
his [ __ ] this is ridiculous the
thing about the con isn't and Roseanne
that lets show watching now I don't
think they used to know the past is like
every storyline is like ah this is stuff
that's going on that dies from opioids
and one of the kids is transsexual and
the you know yeah it's not really
telling stories they're just think we
want to represent the world we live in
today
so it feels like it's not an older show
they wanted to feel like it's happening
right now
yeah but somehow every issue is taking
place inside one household yeah calling
it the corners these people you look at
the picture they shouldn't be living
together no they're all old you don't
have your arms right you see your family
maybe once a year it's like because now
it's basically grandpa's house yeah and
then we all seem to visit at the same
time and then his leave no one's even
living there yeah let's all move in he
lost he lost mom so it's all it's all
move into grandpa's house and then it's
been two years they like get to get out
John Goodman's just like a bag of skin
now he's just a lot of weight a lot of
ways I don't know I mean these old
people that lose weight
I guess it's healthy but they all end up
looking 80 years older they all look
like geriatric when they start losing
John you got to lose the weight yeah
yeah yes
like Clinton looks horrible look at the
skin cares no elasticity it just kind of
rich rich Clinton bill bill
yeah but Billy you see bill down you're
like oh my god is he sickly no no he's
very very healthy what hello he doesn't
like he's recovered from he'd be tipping
80 70 to 72 exactly you never want that
when you're 72 it's only 72 [ __ ] that's
a she's like my my grandmother when she
died it like 73 she looked like she was
[ __ ] a hundred right he looked like
death what she died of
oh just all day just something it wasn't
like a stroke or anything she just never
looked healthy yeah yeah my mother my
mother's thought she was dying a whole
life she thinks he's dying
yeah this is it she's not doing well I
used to like tell people I know my
mother's really sick she might not pull
through this I was like and then she's
like 77 she's gonna live at the moment
I'm putting my mother into her and no
I'm not putting my mother into a nursing
home but I'm playing to my mother's
going to a nursing home and that's uh
that's a fun little thing to do in life
because I can't you know he's got moving
with me I live in America she couldn't
even fight and also she can she fly
she's too big to fly she let me on the
fly fuse get blood clots in her legs she
couldn't even go to her son's wedding
across the country you know she she has
me on the fly free I've offered to fly
out the you know America and suffer up
it so and also she hasn't moved for many
many years how big is she what outer
Peaks you as well over 300 pounds but
now she's a bit smaller yeah we're used
to watching those like 700 but no no no
but for an Australian that's a big
person right American that's just the
yeah but she wouldn't
she couldn't travel or any anything like
that but now it's oh these giant
government does this thing where you got
to pack six hundred thousand dollars to
put them in the nursing home
Wow and for a good one for a good one
and what happens is after they die you
get it back but they gain all the
interest and stuff like all right so
there's a little bit of an outlay so so
you know they could sell a house and do
it but I'm
I'm gonna do it but there is a there is
like $100,000 option which isn't quite
as nice where you share with that foot
but and I've been holding that over I'm
just like every time she says something
mean about me I'm like guys I've got
this other brochure here you might be
interesting can you theoretically move
her out
no I Oh but while she's there I could in
theory right what's the difference
between the two nerd what's like ice
what's a $600,000 see home and a 100,000
I think we I think you get your own room
and you get probably in Sydney if I we
get a nice view of the harbour or
something like that I would hate having
a room a nursing home yeah yeah if I
have to share a room I will kill myself
[Laughter]
rather than have company she would
rather be dead well mention getting that
point in life you live your whole life
you figured everything out and at the
very end you have to go back to just
living in a room with another person
what if she meant like [ __ ] her Bea
Arthur and she golden gilded up towards
it how old do you reckon was the
youngest golden girl at the beginning of
the season 66 or 67 total yes yeah
younger than we think like I have X's
that are now that age you know like like
early fifties Bruma callahan was oh yes
we're living at our golden years I feel
like like even like over 50 communities
she's 53 so when the series began how do
you she was 60 the she was only 60 when
it when it ended how do you break it to
your mother she said I want to go to
nursing home but you have to come on go
look you gotta go
well I she fell over too many times it
was like she we gave her life let
Nicholas and she was falling over on a
weekly basis and the ambulance oh my
gosh and the analyst was like we kind of
keep shopping okay so my brother gets my
brother gets married and I said to I
should look out for my dad out to
the wedding and I said ma'am I'll fly
you out if a doctor says you can't
otherwise I'll pay for nursing to come
over to the house every day and check on
you every day for a couple of you know
and she goes are no problem so I pay for
this nurse and [ __ ] the nurse left
and within a minute she decided she'd go
to the bathroom for something and she
falls over she falls over [ __ ] naked
and the nurses and coming back for four
hours so but she eventually when the
nurse came back the nurse couldn't lift
the back up and they call it a Mons but
the ambulance knows that who she is and
they're like Carolyn's fallen over again
we're like they're like they go give her
a book to read or something like that
we'll be over in an hour in that time
she's lying naked on the floor she's
rings up during the wedding like I want
to see what's going on this woman with
it tits up around her [ __ ] head lying
on the porcelain floor going it's a
lovely wedding so yeah after a while my
mother felt recently and brokers shut up
shoulder replacement once you're a
certain age you just keep [ __ ]
there's nothing you can do every time
you fall you can't get back up I bought
her one of those chairs where you hit a
button and it helps you stand
uh-huh that's that's your last chair in
it yeah that's it that's it there's no
other chair after that there's no other
bit of designer furniture how does that
work it's like a transformer so you like
it so it's sort of like goes so it's all
like flat so the seat there the backs
there that then you stand against it you
hit the button and then it folds back
into a chair oh okay there you go
there's there's a there's a version of
these these chairs that help you stand
so they tips you out yeah throw you out
it does you yeah it's an ejector seat
for the liver that hard to get up I
guess it is guys eventually we're not
for you but no but I mean like your old
is it 300 pounds I have I have a store
in my house that's very low and then
like sometimes I'm like
and I did it rock back and forth before
I get the momentum I wish this chair
could get up for me I don't understand
why I have to put the effort in yeah
yeah that's it is what what the old
people do is they [ __ ] up houses right
before they sell like they die uh-huh
right before you inherit the house
there's a whole bunch of there's a
[ __ ] bath with a door to a railing
that goes up the stairs yeah a chair
that like a [ __ ] Sopranos mother
wasn't that great when a Janice was
getting [ __ ] from behind with a gun
and you just hear the chair coming down
from the stairs but to quickly put their
clothes back on hey congrats on being an
American citizen oh thank you yeah that
was that was fun
III when you when you do it it's my my
ex I was Canadian and when my baby was
very little I said ah you should
probably get it done so that you know so
that someone else's America and the
family and I remember because I bomb it
gave a very good like you know he was a
good talker Bobby gave it a good like
good like welcome to the country thing
is America and there was like and then
they play like who's a proud American
yeah crying and [ __ ] yeah it's very
sweet and but then like I don't think
Trump rehearsed he's welcome to America
speech like I don't think you got a
writer come in or anything he just what
agency I'm gonna wing it
yeah it's it but it's a recorded thing
it's like it's mine it's gets shown
every week when people are [ __ ] doing
this and then it's just like so you
swear in and congratulations you're in
America everyone hugs and cheers like I
now a message from the president he's
like really great really fantastic just
great well done great country amazing
country fantastic country and then he
goes try there was some line that he
says maybe not assimilate but he goes
like trata try to act like us a bit so
this isn't about bringing your culture
here to forget all that you get sweet we
got what we're doing we did it we are
this morning on the show and I also did
like the official one way
you you go to like it's like a warehouse
can a Convention Center there's
thousands of you 3,000 of you and then
like another 4,000 friends and family
watching like that's it's a big ocean
Toria but they give you a little flag
anyway so then they give you certificate
and then like this is with outside
there's a whole lot of Mexican people
that may be illegal selling you like
frames like hey you want to put it in a
flower I don't buy one of those frames
of you from the five oh yeah how long
did it take you what the X was Sara but
hope Renault in the process from
beginning the end it took about eight
eighteen months like I had my green card
for eight nine years before that and now
suppose you came over and you would do
engage I think I got sponsored by iti
back in the day and and you know I had
enough gigs in the diary no you're
paying enough taxes and stuff Yuki I
applied a few times to get the green
card before I eventually got it and then
I had the green card maybe seven years
you can have it five years before you
actually do it and a lot of people just
keep getting the green card when you do
I thought you know I am an American
child and I like living here and I
thought you know might as well [ __ ]
do it and feel like also it's nice to be
able to commit crimes it says I can't
throw you out can't throw you out every
time I had like like any drugs in my
pocket I was like it's just like I got
accorded the rap on the knuckle is you I
don't know yeah I'm carrying kilos
constantly fine so I give you the
certificate and like I remember this
sense of pride we're like wow he's
[ __ ] sneering and then like I had to
travel soon so I had to go get my
passport so you got into the post office
and then a certificate you fought your
whole life to get and then the lady
behind the counter is just like okay and
she just takes it off here and then
you're like you're gonna mail that back
can I have a copy of anything I don't
worry about I'd say they don't and I go
how long on the Peter go anywhere
between a few weeks and two months and
so like the three weeks come around
you're like I still haven't got it and
then and then they delivered my passport
to me that came and that just came in
the post right not like [ __ ] right
special sign just say my mailbox
I'm Molly famous people can figure in my
mailbox is just outside his [ __ ]
reached in there and grabbed a pusher
position but then the big one was my
certificate came back like a month later
like I'd given up hope on ever having my
citizenship certificate again I was
researching how to get another one it
was just it was just right it was folded
and rolled up and shoved into my box so
I have this very creased little [ __ ]
gold certificate little turd thing on it
and then now it's all shitty crinkled up
because my postman two can't and you had
no arrests or anything like that before
you clean records work but it's but it
is I haven't done nothing really I've
got nothing bad really really bad me
life I don't think that deserves I've
done things where yeah yeah where you go
like yeah you're taking of drugs or gone
over the speed limit or things like that
but nothing too serious where I think
I'm a bad person simply responsibilities
it's a lot different than being a menace
to society anyone cuz you have to anyone
who says that never broken the law
that's [ __ ] you've never broken the
law in any way you've never gotten over
the speed limit jaywalking jaywalking
every single person yeah I defy anyone
to say they've never broken the law yeah
yeah well listen the Jim Jefferies show
season 3 premieres next Tuesday at 10:30
on Comedy Central that's amazing you're
going to be at the Mirage in Las Vegas
Friday and Saturday that's amazing
that's always a fun gig it's always good
yeah are you in control in Vegas or no
what do you mean a difficult place for
you I like if I go to certain places I
just I act worse than another place oh I
so I behave myself I take my girlfriend
just to make sure you're accountable
yeah I become very sick to Salahi in
Vegas I'm like we have to see a show
because I know if I see a show I'm
behaving myself right right we have to
do things that will give a [ __ ] of it
Celine Dion I'm saying something
because my shows are at like 10 p.m. so
I can always catch an early like [ __ ]
Beatles loved show or something else
that's in the casino that you wonder I
think I've sex I'm in the same theater
as Terry Fator oh yeah I've seen that
[ __ ] ventriloquist a couple of times
these all right thing for venture Lucas
and where I kind of like it it's like a
guilty pleasure yeah I know it's stupid
it's a [ __ ] kind of in a puppet
exacting like he's lip stop moving but
it's entertaining
yeah it's pretending it's two people but
it's really just him when you see that
when you see the you know the lips move
you go yeah Otto in Georgia is one of my
favorite things ever yeah well there's
always something I mean I'm always
interested in ventriloquist's like why
would you Jeff Dunham to like why would
you need that puppet to kind of block
the attention away from you you want all
this attention but you want it to go
through the puppet yeah what was it in
your childhood when you bought the first
puppet right and then at what point did
you go no we're going all the way with
this and also it's not just like like it
should just be about the jokes but then
they go oh now I'm gonna drink water
like because I know a guy in Britain who
used to do the puppets and stuff like
that but then he just did ventriloquism
but just got rid of the puppet just did
he show without his lips moving
that's like creepy but it's like well
you gotta be like you gotta be like the
best at it because the point about
having a puppet is if you're a little
bit it's okay cuz people are hopefully
looking at the puppet but if there is no
puppy your lips can't move an inch
I just think [ __ ] we all be angry if
the lips moves
we'd be alright I prefer if they don't
but I get with Otto you didn't care but
if there's no puppet you're like what if
the lips are moving you're going well
why are you trying yeah move your lips
then yeah Otto Otto will like try but
it's that you could tell he got a little
caught up in the moment
there was fun with our okay yeah yeah I
never like never pop it was so dark it's
Brian's blew it yep back yeah the
Kennedy uh yeah the plaza very salty it
was great